would you so we sort of agree that this
isn't fair yeah like this is we're in
the same which is interesting because i
didn't think that was your stance wow
because when we talked about it last
time yeah it was just
was that making some good points
you could say it you can say it
i saw it i saw this and i thought about
what you said last time about how like
if you work your whole life with
something it's just like man like i i
would cry i don't care if i got second
place i would cry like yo i've worked so
hard did all the training for this i
don't even know
when she started training for this
i honestly wonder if
and i'm not discrediting her but i i
honestly wonder if
she didn't
how how hard she trained for it to be
able to do it because
essentially she wouldn't have to train
that hard at all to be able to demolish
a record and come in
essentially it's michael michael phelps
the wingspan that
leah has is michael phelps swimming out
there and it's like you can't
you have five six inches of somebody and
your wingspan is just as long as your
height is like there's there's nothing
you can change about that that's
something that physically
you can't inject growth hormones in your
body the night before you find out that
you're swimming against this person
and try to be able to make it a level
playing field in a even playing field
and it sucks because
the there's people who are
trans women that are able to play but
then you have women who are born
biologically a woman they just
were gifted with more testosterone than
regular women that aren't able to
compete in their sport that they
are
biologically a woman in i want